o tema que eu trago pra compartilhar com
vocês hoje é um tema instigante para o
ser humano porque o tema da liberdade é
instigante porque embora muito embora do
ponto de vista ontológico seja quando
nós vamos analisar profundamente a
realidade do ser uma realidade das
coisas
a liberdade não existe ela não exista é
nós inventamos para não enlouquecer
então nós criamos uma série de elementos
para criar um tipo de codificação social
que pudesse facilitar o entendimento do
que é ser livre então nós temos a
liberdade do ser a liberdade de
expressão a liberdade política e nós
valorizamos muito esse espaço construído
socialmente mas lá no fundo existe um
momento em que é muito mais definidor da
minha liberdade da liberdade do outro
quando eu sou capaz pouco em que medida
eu vivo o mundo em que medida o
experimento esse mundo e como eu vejo o
outro nesse mundo que o experimento e se
essa vai ser a medida que vai nos dá a a
idéia real se nós estamos próximo antes
o próximo sou afastado desse código da
liberdade
então com isso porque nós acabamos de
criar algo que não existe para
experimentar concretamente nozes
oficialmente a liberdade nós habitamos
profundamente um paradoxo que é o
paradoxo mais maravilhoso o mais
fundamental talvez da existência humana
que é esse paradoxo entre esses dois
pólos incríveis de um pólo aqui nós
temos essa experiência do infinito do
infinito dentro do ser e isso de tempos
imemoriais os estudos devem se lembrar
quando lá nos primórdios a gente olhava
para o céu
experimentava e tentava compreender algo
que era o desconhecido que é o infinito
desconhecido essa experiência nós
começamos com uma mística de bom depois
vamos para a ciência numa tentativa de
trazer esse infinito pra dentro
bonito são aqui nós já sabemos que isso
é literalmente impossível
muito dessas cabeças desses braços e
dessas pernas o infinito ficaram de fora
de mim
ficam de fora de mim porque a minha
finitude ela é incompatível com a
colocação desse infinito desse
desconhecido tudo em mim especialmente
porque quando nós pensamos no robô que
foi um cara que a gente tem até um
telescópio em homenagem a ele
lá nos anos de 1936 ele disse o seguinte
a astronomia é o estudo de um horizonte
que sempre se afasta
então quanto mais nós tentamos colocar
esse infinito pra dentro o nosso filtro
foi sempre o que esse o que deixa
indefinido infinito eu posso porque
desse infinito eu reconheço tinha sempre
um filtro da minha própria moral como eu
posso pôr alguma coisa que é
absolutamente desconfortável ou
absolutamente desconfortante pra dentro
de mim quando eu busco na verdade uma
mínima estabilização se entendem é um é
uma situação extremamente complexa essa
de fazer esse movimento de trazer o
infinito pra cá o infinito pra dentro do
ser e tem um outro pólo que é bastante
instigante que é quando a gente fez o
contrário e platão já dizia platão dizia
a minha alma me força a olhar para o céu
e olhar pra cima e sair de mim e atrás
do desconhecido então isso a gente sabe
a história toda que que aconteceu após
platão o tanto que é esse foi contido
esse impulso da natureza da alma de
investigar e de influir no infinito nós
sabemos por por não tem 500 anos que a
gente ainda pensava que a terra era o
centro de todo o universo
então essa condição do ser se projetar
no infinito é bastante eberle cosa ela
exige muita coragem
ela exige muita disposição para você
poder é abrir mão de um circuito onde
você relativamente se conhece para pisar
fora dele e invadir esse desconhecido e
não esperar que ao longo do desconhecido
que você permite
de entrar em você a dentre esses eu
circulo essa é a medida é uma medida de
espetacular é onde eu comuniquei pra mim
mesma que é o meu trajecto do conhecido
por um desconhecido que vai me realizar
com isso nós criamos duas matrizes e
nessas duas matrizes todo toda a
experiência de liberdade do ser humano
que assenta ou toda a experiência de
aprisionamento do ser humano se assenta
na experiência onde eu trago infinito
pra dentro de mim que é uma experiência
basicamente intelectual do desconhecido
em contrapartida com a experiência onde
eu meu conhecido se lança numa viagem
pelo desconhecido que é uma experiência
completamente espiritual da liberdade e
por favor não me entendam mal espiritual
eu não quero dizer é de forma nenhuma
nada místico nem tão-pouco
necessariamente algo religioso mas o
simples fato de eu poder fluir com o
impulso da minha alma
então nessa matriz nós geramos um
problema muito conhecido pra quem é
médico pra quem é psicólogo e pra e para
nós que somos amigos e amantes das
pessoas
nós geramos um tipo de paranóia de estar
bem e certamente vocês conhecem e os que
eu estou dizendo são pessoas que
precisam o tempo todo está na sua zona
de conforto são pessoas que não podem
abdicar de uma satisfação emocional
imediata
são na verdade seres humanos muito
infantis é se esses seres humanos talvez
a caricatura mais é perfeita dele é uma
pessoa que nasceu 70 80 anos tem 1
minuto de lucidez
olha pra trás e fala o seguinte bom os
mais difíceis anos da minha vida foram
50 primeiros anos da infância é é um
depoimento triste mas é um momento de
lucidez
então nessa perspectiva é nós não
aprendemos nem na família na escola
lidar com as nossas frustrações
todas as vezes que o nosso ego recebe um
não ou a suposta é a nossa
a proposta busca por realização de todos
os nossos desejos recebe um não nós não
sabemos o que fazer com que ele não e
sucumbimos e energia - um círculo que é
o que eu chamo aqui de uma moral onde o
mesmo em punho os meus ms digo só
pertence a mim aqueles que me fazem bem
só pertencem a mim as idéias que me
querem bem
só pertencem a mim aqueles que forem
igual iguais a mim se desentendem a um
empobrecimento que essa experiência ela
traz
ela leva à criação de adultos inversis
infantis são adultos que não aprenderam
a cair e portanto não aprenderam a se
reerguer
é ao contrário desse outro nessa outra
matriz
eu chamo essa aqui de matriz de
realização de desejos e essa aqui eu
chamo de matrizes de realização de
propósitos não há crise de realização de
propósitos
o que eu tenho é um ser humano que
aprendeu como a gente costuma dizendo
com daline órgão no cic da arma a gente
tem um tempo pra isso que se chama diva
no catar e significa morrer em vida
nós aprendemos tantas vezes a morrer em
vida nós aprendemos tantas vezes a lidar
com a nossa própria frustração e quando
a gente retoma a nossa vida
seguramente nós somos mais autêntico
seguramente nós somos mais fortes e
seguramente nós somos mais singulares
alguém me perguntava a ontem o que me
faz plural e o que me espaço plural é a
minha singularidade é então essa esse
paradoxo é a coisa mais maravilhosa da
vida e é onde por exemplo com daniel e
nós jamais abrimos mãos de cláudia mão
de qualquer paradoxo ele a base pulsante
da nossa vida é da mesma maneira que nós
temos nesses nessas duas matrizes aqui
uma experiência de morrer em vida que me
faz muito apta a princial desconhecido
me faz muito aberta ao desconhecido e é
justamente essa abertura que eu tenho
outro conhecido que me faz é fazer o que
platão sugeriu a tantos milênios atrás
e aqui nós criamos na verdade uma ética
ao contrário de uma moral essa ética eu
não quis
só está em mim e eu quero estar no outro
também porque o desconhecido do outro e
é importante e é o desconhecido do outro
na contradição do outro que eu vou
aprender mais sobre mim
então basicamente é esse e se essas duas
matrizes elas acolhem toda a ideia que o
mundo moderno tem de liberdade ou de
prisão
e aí é é óbvio que a gente nos resta nos
restam dois caminhos eles são bem
simples eu tentei sintetizar para dar a
vocês um pouco de uma ideia é muito
complexa
a favela fica muito fácil de ser
digerida é que essa idéia de você se
colocar numa determinada situação e você
ter dois caminhos ou você torna se um
prisioneiro das demandas infindáveis no
seu ego e você coloca todo o seu
combustível emocional a responder essas
demandas do ego eu não tenho nada contra
o ego inclusive eu acho muito bom e se
nós formos vivos nós somos vivos porque
nós temos um ego
mas uma coisa é o ego apartado de um
espírito é aquele que busca
instantaneamente imediatamente um
conforto emocional que me faz ficar
muito frágil então a minha rota de 7 de
satisfação de desejos imediatos ela vai
me levar pra uma busca muito é paranóica
de segurança porque eu não tenho
segurança em mim e eu tenho que buscar a
segurança em todos aqueles que se
aproxima todo desconhecido que se
aproxima de mim nem que me garante que
eu estarei seguro com eles vocês
entendem a a mudança de perspectiva eu
só pertence a mim aqueles que me dão
conforto e segurança
então eu aprendi com o bb a fazer birras
e como adulto eu continuo eu continuo
dramatizando para alcançar aquilo que eu
quero
a outra rota possível é a rota onde eu
pego todo esse combustível emocional e
coloco ele a serviço do meu ímpeto eu
coloco ele a serviço da minha
singularidade e coloca a serviço da
minha exposição a romper todo tipo de
bairro
e me apaixonar me tornar cada vez mais
apaixonada pela experiência
essa condição ela só é possível porque
pra alma ao contrário do ego
só existe um motivador a experiência e
não uma garantia prévia de que a
experiência será boa para a alma isso
pouco importa a alma é o desconhecido
ela é o infinito para ela quanto mais
experiências mas eu vou saber do meu
desconhecido e mais eu vou ficar aberta
por desconhecido imediatamente à minha
frente que é o outro
eu não preciso ir para as estrelas do
universo eu posso ir justamente no céu à
minha frente que é o outro e assim é o
finalizar com vocês e eu acho que o
teste do grau da minha liberdade não
está no quanto eu conheço
intelectualmente da liberdade e o quanto
eu falo dela
o teste da minha liberdade é um teste da
minha espiritualidade é um teste do meu
espírito ele quer dizer o seguinte
quando eu for confrontado pelo finito
mais insolente mais radical que é o da
dor e do sofrimento se eu encontro em si
finito que é colocado diante de mim com
o meu finito ou com o meu infinito
se eu for encontrar o finito do
desconforto da dor da contradição com o
meu finito com certeza eu vou
recrudescer no meu círculo eu vou
cristalizar no meu modelo de passado e
vou fazer o meu modelo de passado o meu
futuro mas se ao contrário eu encontro
esse infinito doloroso insofismável com
o meu infinito eu tenho uma chance de
fazer o que a evolução espera de mim que
eu mude que eu me adapte que ele renove
e que eu acorde de um tombo e me sinta
uma pessoa viva e absolutamente nova
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
o gado